black lives matter is saying the united
states is denying them the right to
choose their own government
uh you know what really undermines
cubans rights issues their own
government the fact that they haven't
held a vote since 1962.
they're a communist group period end of
story
and no responsible person should be
associated with it i have to say the
left's perspective on this is absolutely
astonishing the left
in america because for people who really
say that what they want is denmark or
norway
they have a really tough time simply
condemning communism they have a really
rough time saying
that these regimes are evil and bad i
think bernie sanders a couple of days to
comment when he did comment he read
directly from the howard's in playbook
where he talked about how it was really
the united states embargo that was the
problem
in cuba and now you have black lives
matter sounding off
the movement now let me remind you black
lives matter is a semantically
overloaded term
there's some people who when they say
black lives matter mean the perfectly
obvious thing which is that black lives
matter
just like every life matters and black
people should not be targeted by the
police
more than anybody else should be
targeted by the police right that's
perfectly obvious but
the black lives matter organization
which is raked in tens of millions of
dollars
and fostered not just protests but riots
in cities
around the united states and is run by
open communists
they put out it's just a garbage
organization it's been a garbage
organization since it was it was founded
in in the mid 2010s and it's its
founders
are openly marxist in orientation
meanwhile skimming off the top
presumably
or allegedly in order to go by
themselves really really nice houses in
tobago canyon
so black lives matter the organization
which remember you had corporations
donating millions of dollars to yet
people posting black squares in support
of the organization
not just the generalized idea in favor
this organization is a garbage can a
garbage communist organization
so far when it comes to world issues
they have
supported the the hamas terrorists in
the gaza war and now they support the
communist cuban regime
and it is telling here is what they say
quote black lives matter
condemns the us federal government
inhumane treatment of cubans
now you may have noticed that the u.s
federal government does not actually run
cuba and they're not the people
arresting youtube stars
or shooting people in the streets black
lives matter condemns
the u.s federal government's inhumane
treatment of cubans and urges it to
immediately lift the economic embargo
this cruel and inhumane policy
instituted with the explicit intention
of destabilizing the country
and undermining cuban's right to choose
their own government is at the heart of
cuba's current crisis
since 1962 the united states has forced
pain and suffering on the people of cuba
by cutting off food medicine and
supplies
costing the tiny island nation an
estimated 130 billion dollars so you see
it's all the
fault of the united states amazing it's
all the fault of the united states
according to black lives matter because
according to black lives matter the west
is always wrong
according to the black lives matter
organization the organization that
millions tens of millions of americans
marched with last year
this according to this organization
america is a terrible place and is
responsible for all the world's elves
why would you trust them when it comes
to the cops
to the systems of power in the united
states why would you trust them with
regard to anything
they're a communist group period end of
story
and here they are repeating communist
propaganda my favorite part of this
particular paragraph
is where they say the united states has
been undermining cuba's right to choose
its own government
uh you know what really undermines
cubans rights issues their own
government the fact that they haven't
held a vote since 1962.
they didn't in 1962 either okay so
it's been six decades since the cuban
revolution
and the uh and the communist regime
there has never allowed a free and fair
election
and black lives matter is saying the
united states is denying them the right
to choose their own government
because blm again is a garbage
organization i can't say it too many
times
let me reiterate say it real slowly for
those of you who are having a tough time
black lives matter the organization is
garbage
should be condemned and no responsible
person should be associated with it
blm continues without that money it is
harder for cuba to acquire medical
equipment needed to develop its own
coven-19 vaccines
and equipment for food production this
comes in spite of the country's strong
medical care and history of lending
doctors and nurses to disasters around
the world
uh it wouldn't be complete statement
without a bit of propagandizing on
behalf of the cuban health care system
which by the way
is so lacking the cuban health care
system they couldn't get covet 19
vaccines into the arms of people in cuba
says blm the people of cuba are being
punished by the us government because
the country has maintained its
commitment to sovereignty and
self-determination
yes nothing says sovereignty and
self-determination quite like
throwing tens of thousands of people
over the years in prison forcing people
to float in jerry-rigged canoes
basically across
100 miles of shark infested ocean to get
to florida
self-determine it sounds like
self-determination when you don't allow
anybody to vote ever it's it really is
it's amazing levels of
self-determination here
blm says united states leaders have
tried to crush this revolution for
decades instead of international amity
respecting goodwill the us government
has only instigated suffering for the
country's 11 million people
of which 4 million are black and brown
uh there it is
it's because the us is racist of course
because everything comes down to racism
for black lives matter remember the
crossover between the
the racial reckoning that we are having
via groups like blm
and the full-on marxist agenda of many
of these groups
is very heavy indeed in the same way the
critical racial theory
is very much connected to the idea that
the institutions of capitalism and
individual rights have to be torn down
derek bell was very clear about this in
his own writings
says black lives matter cuba has
historically demonstrated solidarity
with oppressed people of african descent
okay if by that they mean that cuba has
shipped troops
to places in africa to help establish
communist regimes there and kill
black people in defense of those
communist regimes that would be correct
from protecting black revolutionaries
like asada shakur
through granting her asylum to
supporting black liberation struggles
in angola mozambique guinea-bissau and
south africa
unbelievable but totally believable now
we look to president biden to end the
embargo something barack obama called
for in 2016. this embargoes a blatant
human rights violation and it must come
to an end
now why bother reading the entire blm
statement because blm
the organization is not dissociated from
the
generalized democratic party they are
not the democratic party still refuses
to condemn blm as an organization
its leaders still hobnob with blm
and it is not a coincidence that this
administration the bide administration
is having an extremely
tough time speaking moral words about
what is happening in cuba right now
for example shinsaki was asked yesterday
whether the biden administration would
put out a statement condemning communism
right now would seem a good time now the
bite administration has taken the tactic
of attempting to minimize what is going
on in cuba
they say that the current cuban unrest
that the the massive protests in the
streets are not
driven by cuban communism per se instead
they are driven by something else they
are driven by mismanagement
right it's the mismanagement that's the
problem if the communists were just good
managers then everything would be fine
but the communists are bad managers and
so it's a little bit bad but it has
nothing to do with communism
per se so here is gensake being asked
about condemning communism and
shying away from it do you think that
people are leaving cuba because they
don't like communism
i think we've been pretty clear that we
think people are leaving cuba or not
leaving cuba or protesting in the
streets all as well because
uh they are opposed to the oppression to
the mismanagement of the government
in the country and we certainly support
their rights of protest we support
uh their efforts to speak out against
their treatment in cuba hmm
i'm noticing a word missing there
oppression and mismanagement if it
weren't for the oppression mismanagement
communism
it's a beautiful idea she's never worked
in in practice
guys that's that's it true communism has
never been tried if only they could just
get
rid of the oppression and mismanagement
that would solve it and then she's asked
again
like so are you guys going to put out a
statement condemning communism at any
point here
yeah nah well we hear from the president
this week he said the other day that he
would speak out on that and and secondly
is is his position still that he feels
the trump policies were a failure didn't
affect change is that still his policy
well again i would say uh one in terms
of whether he healed from him
he says that often as you know and what
he means is he speaks
out publicly nearly every day at events
sometimes you all ask questions if
there's an update to provide
on what we're doing on what our policies
are certainly he'll provide that
is there a planned speech or trip not at
this time uh there's no planned speech
or trip
again it's amazing how hard a time the
left the squad
even the mainstream democratic party has
simply saying communism is evil
and back in the 1960s the democratic
party didn't have any problem saying
communism was evil
but then something turned and the sort
of
soft fellow traveler sensibility that
bernie sanders carries around with
regard to communist regimes has infused
large swaths of the democratic party and
it's quite awful and it's quite
disgusting and it demonstrates once
again
that domestically speaking the
people who believe in the basic tenets
of marxism which is that the united
states
is a class struggle which has never been
historically true in the united states
the united states is not about class in
the same way that europe was about class
that are not these hard
sort of hard and fast classes from which
people can never move
but the the folks who purport to say
that this is what america is all about
they are they are completely unwilling
to condemn actual oppression by
communists
on a global scale and this does go back
to the cold war when the left in the
united states
played ftse with communist regimes
throughout the world and refused to
condemn them throughout the 70s and 80s
particularly
apparently not very much has changed
which is uh pretty shocking
by the way it is there is a reminder to
be had here
that barack obama and his administration
were quite friendly to the cuban regime
you'll recall that you traveled to cuba
he hung out with royal castro he held
hands with the guy
he went to a baseball game with him and
then he prays the cuban dictator
it so nothing new under the sun
i said this to president castro in cuba
i said look you've made great progress
in educating
uh chil uh young people every child in
cuba
gets a basic education that's that's a a
huge improvement from where it was
medical care you know the
the life expectancy of cubans is
equivalent to the united states despite
it being a very poor country because
they have access to health care that's a
huge achievement
they should be congratulated oh well and
then amazing they should they should be
congratulated
the cubans for for you know having been
dominated by a communist regime
for quite a while why does the left have
such a tough time with us why they have
such a tough time
condemning an actual communist
dictatorship i think the answer is
fairly obvious they have a lot of
sympathy for the ideas that undergird
the communist dictatorship
that would be the only rationale for why
they are having such a tough time with
this one
this is not a hard one forget about the
sort of policy prescriptions here
the moral statement that communism is a
great evil should not be tough
and yet for a lot of folks apparently it
really really is
i will say i think my favorite media
take on this over the last couple of
days
there's a take from reuters here is the
the headline
quote cuban protests risk exacerbating a
covet 19 spike
so we are now back to the 2020 headlines
wherein if you gather to protest lotte
you're going to spread covet but
if you gathered to dance in defense of
george floyd
then you're definitely not going to
spread covet all i can say is communism
is a public health crisis
just like racism was supposedly a public
health crisis communism
in cuba is much more of a public health
crisis than racism in the united states
has been for quite
a long time the battle for the culture
is heating up we here at the daily wire
are making some big moves so be sure to
like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment